Can you take protocell along with some chemotherapy drugs, and
erobotase inhibitors for metastatic breast cancer, horrible receptor, hurt too
positive, hurt too negative breast cancer, and that's to the abdomen. Yes, you can.
So again, protocell, again, it's totally different person that has this question. It's kind of
hard to get two protocell questions. That's what protocell is. So I write about protocell in my book,
and I think I actually interviewed the maker of protocell for my first edition. I can't
remember. That was about 12 years ago. But yes, you can take protocell with an erobotase,
knowing that the chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent as well, so it'll only count on it that.
But does protocell interfere with the erobotase inhibitor, which will take the hitter's block
hormones? No, it doesn't at all. You can take it at that cell, or it's no issue that's eating one of those.